this is a production of cornell
university
well great thanks a lot for the
introduction andy um
yeah as andy mentioned i'm just
beginning my second year
and these are really some initial
thoughts for my research plan i'm really
looking forward to your
your feedback and questions at the end
or or another day if we run out of time
but i'm going to be talking about uh
some of our research related to
agricultural burning
in bihar india
oops
there we go all right so the area of
interest that i'll be talking about
today is
bihar state it's on the eastern side of
the endogenic plains
and uh our our lab group works very
closely with cement in south asia and
particularly
sisa the sisa team the cereal systems
initiative for south asia
and this this group works on multiple
sustainable intensification
challenges and serial systems now bihar
in particular
is a major priority region for the
government
of india in their future food security
goals this area has a very
unfortunately astonishing yield gaps and
there's been a lot of investment in
multiple different capacities to
intensify agriculture but then of course
with this intensification also results
in some increased
environmental pressures and other
sustainability challenges
such as burning so we got together
a group of people like annie mentioned
to apply for
the atkinson center academic venture
fund
and so we were able to bring together
excuse me for a moment
we were able to bring together a really
multi-disciplinary team from across
cornell and summit
bringing together individuals in
agronomy atmospheric sciences
policy economics um even anthropology
to really look at the changes that are
happening in bihar
and from a very multi-disciplinary um
multifaceted approach so so
it's exciting to be to be a part of this
but first let's start off
and i'll get on the same page on what
crop residue burning is
in the context of south asia now burning
is a method used to quickly remove crop
residue from the surface
and clear the field for the next crop
these are primarily
rice and wheat systems and burning tends
to happen with
or is most common in the rice with the
rice residue
and it's a pro it's an approach that's
taken when the straw has little to no
value
so that could be that once maybe the the
straw had a value as a livestock fodder
but not anymore
or their the economics just don't match
up between what it would cost
time and money to remove it and
transport it
and so essentially lighting a match and
burning it is
unfortunately a quick solution to get
rid of the residue
but this unfortunately does contribute
to major health qual or health
air quality issues and public health
issues
and actually we are in a timely this is
a timely moment for this talk we're
entering right now beginning of november
the the peak
season of residue burning and air
quality issues
in northwest india it
some say that it's equivalent of two
packs of particulate matter 2.5
per day and schools close
just real it's really bad situation air
quality wise
but burning also contributes to
long-term yield decreases
due to decreases in sow quality and then
also has negative implications on
greenhouse gas emissions
so here i have a screenshot from last
year during the one month peak
burning season of rice draw and you can
see
here in the northwest western genetic
plane
uh that the fire count so each each red
point here is a fire observation from
a satellite so we have we have
the northwest being the primary hot spot
for burning
this time of year coupled with other
environmental conditions it just
creates this massive air quality crisis
in the region
and there's been a lot of investment to
try to deal with this issue
with apache success
for those of you who aren't familiar
with this context in india it's the
considered the bread basket of indian a
very intensive rice wheat system
irrigated mechanized particularly with
combine harvesters
and actually the combine harvesters have
a very close link
with burning that i'll talk about in
more detail later
but our area of interest for today and
i'll just note that we are doing work in
the northwest
but i'll focus on on bihar for today's
talk
in the east only about 10 of farmers
are burning but what's alarming is that
this rate has
doubled in the past 10 years this is
just a quick time series plot of the
last 17 years
and this is an annual fire count from
across the state and you can see that
really
that this upward trend is is really
alarming
and it it it puts major concern
or brings into major concern of what
air quality might look like in patna in
five ten years if this
continues patna already is struggling
with air quality issues
and in this type of scenario in five ten
years could really put potnet the risk
of some of the challenges that delhi
area is
in new delhi specifically are facing
with air quality
so this research presents a unique
opportunity to get ahead of this
emerging problem
essentially understand this issue before
before
it's too late or the problem is already
so massive that it's difficult to handle
so
it's a new unique opportunity to one use
geostatistics
to understand what's going on with
burning and then also our on the ground
agronomic networks to like i said
quantify
what's happened with burning and the
reasons behind it and hopefully
use these pieces to inform policy
so i mentioned very briefly that
agriculture
is intensifying in the state
but more specifically i'm just going to
pull out a couple other pieces
of other hypotheses that we think are
driving these
recent semi well recent increases in
burning
so first off we have changes in labor
availability
specifically labor shortages
and this really mediates combine
use while mechanization but specifically
combine use
and also livestock ownership at the
household level
now traditionally in these systems rice
was harvested by hand or is still in
many places right so harvested by hand
bundled and stored and fed as a
livestock fodder
now with labor shortages the combine
is a an attractive alternative
unfortunately with the combine what
happens with the straws it gets fed into
the inside of the combine it gets bent
broken and sent out the back
essentially rendering it useless for
for our fodders very difficult to store
as well
and so and so often times the straws
burn after the combine comes through
so and then when it comes to livestock
these are in bihar these are
these are extensive crop livestock
systems
and we're seeing anecdotally a
decoupling of the livestock crops
or the crop livestock system and
essentially a
intensification or a consolidation of
the milk value chain
so we're seeing a lot of different
trends in this system that might be
related to
the change in burning but zooming out a
little bit
i'd like to present to you what
the project that was recently funded by
the atkinson center
academic venture fund and it has four
main components
first which i'll talk in more detail
today
is a naive and factor based burning
modeling of burning we'll also be
looking at air quality modeling
and coupling that with disease burden
estimations
and then also all of that feeding into
scenario analyses
of agricultural productivity and
greenhouse gas emissions
and all these pieces will come together
and provide
evidence-based policy intervention
design
but most importantly it will be
co-constructed
with the state government of bihar
and um and it is a timely it is
we're fortunate to be in this or where
it's good timing and the fact that
bihar officials are very
concerned about this looming these
looming changes of burning
um and and yet little has really been
been studied and um
on on this topic so it's a a good
opportunity
to form policy
so getting into the next three pieces
this naive and factor-based modeling of
burning
we want to understand the what why and
what's
what's next first what's happening we
want to understand the spatial
and temporal burning patterns of
of rice residue burning and then why
what what are the potential of drivers
drivers of change
that are resulting in these burning
patterns
and then finally what's what's next
develop
scenarios of development trajectories
and engage policy makers
so we'll begin with the what our data
sources
for understanding the past fire trends
are our two earth observation satellites
viers and modis
modis has the great benefit of having a
long time span
since 2003 we have we have
we have a large amount of data and
beers however while it has a shorter
time span the spatial
resolution is finer and does capture a
larger or greater number of fires
one of the approaches we're using for
these analysis is
point pattern analysis and i'll show you
three plots here from 2012
2015 and 2018
and just looking at these fire points
from across
space and time a visual estimation tells
us
shows us yes fires are increasing across
the state
but you can also see there that the
density of points
is much greater in the western part of
the state
and if you look closely moving you can
almost see the points moving from
west to east and which gives insight to
some type of
technology frontier per se we can
we can use fires as a proxy for combine
adoption and so in this way remote
sensing gives us a really unique
a very unique opportunity to really
understand technological
change across time and space that we
would not be able to
do in this level of detail otherwise for
example
we could for example on the ground
household surveys could provide some
type of insight on combine
adoption but it'd be very difficult to
get this level of detail
and this expansive panel data
of this information so with point
pattern analysis alone
we could predict future fire patterns
locations amount locations and intensity
but it brings us to the why if we can
understand the drivers of change
especially thinking about how these
drivers of change
are likely to be heterogeneous across
the state
and that there will be some variation we
can build prediction models that are
much more much more detailed and can
really strengthen our models
so thinking back to the hypotheses that
i presented
earlier the system in the system
these drivers are complex they're
dynamic
and it will take a couple different
efforts
to understand what's going on in this
system so first it'll
we'll be doing a series of household
surveys uh we'll also be conducting
key informant interviews with
individuals in the residue markets
individuals in the milk value chains and
then also individuals
in the combine service provide provision
and and while this piece of the research
is
very preliminary we have completed the
first step
which was of the first round of a
household survey across the state of
bihar
in 30 of the 38 districts
and while these results are preliminary
it does i want to share a couple things
here that will give us
some insight into some of these
these notions that we were thinking
about earlier so over the past five
years
respondents households reported that
yes in fact livestock ownership is going
down
is decreasing and at the same time
there's a notion that combine adoption
is increasing however if you look
to the plot on the right what this is
showing
this is the percentage of rice fields
harvested by combine
so we asked individuals
okay if you adopted the combine what
percentage of your rice fields did you
adopt the combine and you can see that
the majority
of individuals actually
partially adopted the combine adopt are
using it on
50 or 60 percent or so of their fields
now these individuals owned an average
of 4.5
livestock per household
there were however full adopters
adopting the combine on all their fields
using the combine on all their fields
these individuals own much less
1.5 livestock per household and so we
asked these partial adopters
why why only partially adopt and the
majority responded that non-combined
fields were mainly
harvested to preserve straw for
livestock feeding
and so we do get this sense that
households that
value livestock will adopt technology
but perhaps a little bit differently
and if they're adopting technology the
combine a little bit differently
that may result in different outcomes
for burning
and so and so the story builds but it
does provide some insight
into what might be happening and some of
the complex dynamics
of the system
and so finally what's next
so thinking back to the the big the four
big objectives from this
atkinson center funded project we gather
up
all these pieces essentially the burning
models the burning forecasts
understanding the drivers of change
having those integrated into the models
public health implications crop
productivity greenhouse gas emissions
a lot of this is coming from other
secondary sources
we're bringing these all together to
build scenario models to understand the
burdens
essentially the burdens the public
private cost
of of burning and so
the goal is to say okay in five ten
years
if business as usual continues with
burning
what's that going to cost what's the
public and private cost of that
but we'd also like to say okay there's
some other alternatives here
if we look at alternative one
alternative two
that the costs will decrease or or
maybe burning depending on what happens
we can
slow down or stop burning altogether
and so these really require
a co-creation of creative solutions in
fact you can see here
on the on the left hand side here we
have something called a happy seeder
and this is a piece of equipment that
allows
allows you to plant into deep residue
into thick residue
and this um this has really been
promoted in the northwest
as a way to handle this a massive amount
of
residue as an alternative to burning and
yes from a practical stance
this is this can be a way to
to address this this challenge is all
this residue but
but in reality adoption is a bit
scattered it's
sparse it's expensive there's a short
time between
harvest and planting so this alone yes
while it can be helpful
we we know that technology mechanization
is not the only solution and so we also
we need to think about solutions that
may be
related to rural infrastructure maybe
thinking about
where milk drop-off stations are located
to support
the continuation of crop livestock
integration
maybe maybe the new solutions are
related to
residue markets and thinking about other
purposes or just
kind of thinking about ways that these
all relate and that
burning can be addressed in this
multi-faceted way
and and then leverage key key points in
the system
so thank you very much and i look
forward to your
questions and feedback
uh emily and i have a question sure um
is there uh any uh use of uh
post combining baling of the straw to
make it a little bit easier to handle
and get it off more quickly and secondly
another
completely different alternative uh a
sort of chopping device that would be at
the uh
at the outlet on the combine that would
chop that straw into smaller pieces that
would be
less objectionable to leave on the field
yeah these are these are good questions
yep baileyness is
definitely an option that a lot of
people have looked at and
and then the big question is what's next
so having bail making subsidizing
machines to bail will essentially move
the residue get it out of the field
but there's really a whole value chain
of thinking about what's next so
whether that's moving these bales into
areas for livestock fodder
or or other there's been other
initiatives where
um the straw has been used as a as a
biofuel or it's been burnt and um
and the big challenge is is the
transportation and just making
and making the economics viable behind
that
as far as choppers i know there's
there's um
and we're actually seeing this from this
first household survey there
is kind of a new business opportunity
for service providers to provide
chopping so
um and then storing fodder that way but
i'm not sure of any
institute field um and maybe andy could
actually speak to this better about the
choppers thank you actually emily what i
was thinking is
is nothing terribly uh not not a really
big deal
it's very common in combines that we use
in
small grains in the united states to
have right at the outlet of the
of the combine it can chop it up into
small pieces
and and so that's uh just incorporated
right into the combine
and it's a small it's a small power
requirement i believe
but it doesn't cut it into really really
tiny bits like
in silage it's cutting it into i don't
know six eight inch pieces
which which tim is is great if you have
the equipment to sew
into loose residue i mean it opens up
some different avenues but
by and large outside of the happy cedar
none of the drills can handle that
it does help a little bit with
incorporation and in some of the the
areas in northwest india they they have
a separate machine
that is a straw chopper that runs behind
the combines
i haven't seen it integrated um we have
things like the
straw management system which spreads
evenly which makes it a little bit
easier to sew into but
yeah there's lots of things that could
be done in the east it's all about cost
uh and it's a different equation
incidentally emily uh what do they do
with the wheat
they use the same combine
ah so um
so i know so there's some different
dynamic a little bit different dynamics
with with wheat
one of the one of the key pressure
points with the rice burning
is there's a very short planting
planting period
between the rice harvest and the wheat
planting with
the with the wheat harvest there's a
much longer
delay right so a lot of essential
there's time
to look at different solutions um
and and do something with it but there
is also some burning with the wheat
as well yeah and also after the weed it
gets dry
right so it's a it's easy to uh
to get a good quality straw after the
weep
because of the drying that takes place
yeah that's a good point
i think some questions
just uh one one interesting thing emily
is that
in the east the farmers tend to feed
rice straw to their animals in the west
northwest they use
wheat straw and and what happened you
know they've been combining first
started in the northwest
and so those farmers have actually
switched from having animals to your
livestock from being
there for tillage um to actually
switch to dairy so they usually collect
the
they will actually pick up the straw
after wheat harvest
and bail it and use that as feed for the
rest of the year in northwest
in in eastern india um are they
the question is are they switching when
they
you say there's a reduction in livestock
because this reduction in livestock
due to um uh a switch
you know just uh livestock per se or
how are they switching from land
preparation to dairy
which is what they've done in north west
yeah yeah no that's a good question i
think that the true answer is we need to
this is part of
part of trying to figure out what's
what's happening with the livestock
numbers there's very little publicly
available data on livestock numbers and
what that is whether they're
whether they're for for working the
field or for or dairy
um the other the other question is
livestock numbers might be going down at
the household but does that necessarily
mean that livestock numbers maybe
there's just
this consolidation of of livestock
production
so if you look at the statewide numbers
that livestock maybe hasn't changed so
much so
this is an area where we definitely need
to
collect more data and understand the key
informant interviews hopefully with the
with individuals in the milk value chain
will hopefully provide some
more depth into those those questions
but thanks for that question and comment
yeah
yeah i i need to spend time talking to
you
great we'll make that happen
okay great any other burning so to speak
questions
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu